DETERMINE THAT TEHRAN IS
USING IT TO FUND THE
TERRORIST GROUP HEZBOLLAH.
BIG SHOCKER.
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER
DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT BOB SNOOZE
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIAN GARR CAN A AND
FORMER U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
THE U.N. FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOHN BOLTON.
DR. GORKA, I LOOK AT THIS
AND I SAY OKAY, IT’S THE
SAME THEME.
THERE IS A COMPULSION ON THE
LEFT TO WANT TO SUCK UP TO
THE WORLD’S WORST DICTATORS.
WHY?
WHY DO THEY THINK THAT
WORKS?
>> LOOK, IT’S NOTHING NEW.
THIS IS WHAT THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" WAS DOING WITH WALTER
WITH THE 120S AND 30’S
SINGING THE PRAISES OF THE
SOVIET UNION THAT STALIN WAS
KILLING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
THIS IS A REGIME -- THIS IS
THE PERSON WHO RUNS
PROPAGANDA TORE A STALL
LIPPIST REGIME THAT’S
STARVING ITS OWN PEOPLE.
WOULD CNN HAVE CELEBRATED
GERBILS?
WOULD THEY HAVE CELEBRATED
THE PROPAGANDA MACHINE OF
HITLER’S THIRD REICH?
IT’S OUTRAGEOUS THE LACK OF
SELF-AWARENESS OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
HAVE YOU MIKE PENCE SITTING
THERE DOING WHAT IS RIGHT,
MORALLY, AND THEY WANT TO
FOCUS ON A KEY MEMBER OF AN
EVIL, EVIL DICK PARITYSHIP?
IT’S BEYOND THE PALE, SEAN.
>>> LOOK AT THESE QUOTES.
CNN, AMBASSADOR, GOING OUT
THERE.
KIM JONG UN’S SISTER
STEALING THE SHOW AT THE
WINTER OLYMPICFULS.
KIM JONG UN’S SISTER
OUTFLANKS VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE IN DIPLOMACY.
WHERE IS THIS DESIRE TO JUST
WORSHIP THE PROPAGANDA
MINISTER OF MOSTLY CLOUDY
WITH THEIR HORRIFIC HUMAN
RIGHTS RECORD?
I THOUGHT THE LEFT CARED
ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> ONLY WHEN IT SUITS THEM.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT’S MORE
THAN THE BIAS.
IT’S THEIR INCOMPETENCE.
IT’S THEIR LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE, THEIR
UNWILLINGNESS TO LOOK.
THEIR LACK OF APPRECIATION
FOR THE FACT THAT THE NORTH
KOREAN PROPAGANDA MACHINE
HAS DONE THIS ALL BEFORE.
THEY HAVE UNIFIED TEAMS
MARCH IN THREE TIEROUS
OLYMPICS.
INTEREST IN INTERKOREAN
SUMMITS IN 2000 AND 2007.
ALL OF WHICH PROPAGANDA IN
WHICH THE CURRENT OLYMPIC
CHARADE IS A PART DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO SLOW
DOWN THE NORTH KOREAN
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN BALLISTIC
MISSILE PROGRAMS.
THAT’S WHAT THE CURRENT
CHARADE IS DOING.
THE MEDIA ARE STENOGRAPHERS
FOR THE NORTH KOREANS AND
THEIR LACK OF HISTORICAL
KNOWLEDGE OR APPRECIATION
SHOWS THEY HAVE THE
ATTENTION SPAN OF FRUIT
FLIES.
>> Sean: I STILL FOR THE
LIFE OF ME HAVE A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING WHY PEOPLE
THINK PEOPLE THAT THREATEN
TO DESTROY YOU.
YOU KNOW, DEATH TO AMERICA.
DEATH TO ISRAEL.
BURN THE ISRAELI FLAG.
BURN THE AMERICAN FLAG.
OH, WHO THINKS IT’S A GOOD
IDEA TO SEND IN CARGO PLANES
FULL OF CASH AND CURRENCY
AND THAT SOMEHOW THE MULLAHS
WILL LIKE US IN IRAN OR THE
DICTATORS IN NORTH KOREA
WILL SOMEHOW CHANGE THEIR
WAYS, DR. GORKA?
>> SEAN, THIS THERE IS A
VERY SIMPLE ANSWER TO ALL OF
THIS.
WHY DO THEY DO THIS?
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE DON’T
LOVE AMERICA.
WHY DID THESE PEOPLE EXCUSE
EVERYTHING OBAMA DID FOR 8
YEARS HAS HE WENT ON AN
APOLOGY TOUR?
>> I DON’T THINK THESE IT I
THINK THEY ACTUALLY THINK IF
YOU KISS THEIR RING AND BOW
BEFORE THEM THEY WILL LIKE
YOU.
HISTORY HAS PROVEN THAT
DOESN’T WORK.
>> WHY COULD YOU DO THAT
WITH A REGIME THAT IS EVIL?
THERE IS A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT HERE WE NEED TO
APPRECIATE.
THE LEFT WING MEDIA ALWAYS
HELPS OUR ENEMIES.
THEY DON’T SUPPORT ISRAEL.
OUR BEST FRIEND NUT MIDDLE
EAST.
THEY SUPPORT IRAN, THINK
ABOUT THAT.
THEY DON’T SUPPORT A GREAT
LONG TIME ALLIES.
THEY SUPPORT THOSE THAT ARE
ANTIMERGE U WHEN IT’S NORTH
KOREA OR IRAN OR CHINA.
IF YOU DON’T LIKE AMERICA,
THEN THE MEDIA WILL LOVE
YOU.
IT’S THAT SIMPLE.
>> Sean: DONALD TRUMP HAS
TAKEN A HARD LINE.
LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
I HAVE A BIGGER BUTTON ON MY
DESK AND OURS ACTUALLY WORKS
WHICH IS I THINK IS
HILARIOUS BUT ALSO SENDS A
STRONG MESSAGE.
>> DO YOU THINK IT HAD ANY
IMPACT ON TIM JONG UN AND
HIS DESIRE TO BE IN THESE
OLYMPICS, POTENTIAL TALKS
WITH SOUTH KOREA?
THERE IS PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
DID IT HAVE ANY IMPACT HERE?
>> I THINK IT’S HAD AN
ENORMOUS IMPACT.
BECAUSE I THINK FOR THE
FIRST TIME CERTAINLY IN 8
YEARS BUT REALLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME SIGNIFICANTLY IN
25 YEARS OF OUR EFFORTS TO
STOP NORTH KOREA FROM
GETTING DELIVERABLE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, I THINK THEY
BELIEVE THAT WHEN DONALD
TRUMP SAYS ALL OPTIONS ARE
ON THE TABLE HE REALLY MEANS
IT AND FOR NORTH KOREA, THIS
IS A VERY CRITICAL PERIOD.
IT IS FOR US, TOO.
BECAUSE THE NORTH IS AS CIA
DIRECTOR MIKE POMPEO SAID
WITHIN A HANDFUL OF MONTHS
OF HAVING THIS DELIVERABLE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS CAPABILITY.
SO I THINK WHAT THE NORTH
WAS TRYING TO DO WAS THROW
UP A PROPAGANDA SCREEN.
HAVE PEOPLE OOOH AND AWEE
FORGET THE IMRIEWRM
CENTRIFUGES STILL SPINNING
AND ROCKET SCIENCES STILL
WORKING IN HONTS THEY CAN
GET ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
BEFORE WE CAN DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
STEVE: IVANKA TRUMP OF NORTH
KOREA, DID THEY
INADVERTENTLY SUGGEST THAT
THINK -- THAT IVANKA TRUMP
IS GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY AND
A BIT OF A STAR?
IT WASN’T ON PURPOSE, I’M
SURE.
>> NO THE GREAT IRONY IF
THIS REALLY WERE AN ANALOGY
WITH IVANKA TRUMP.
THEY WOULD HAVE ATTACKED
THIS WOMAN JUST AS THEY HAVE
ATTACKED EVERYBODY IN THE
PRESIDENT’S FAMILY SINCE HE
BECAME THE PRESIDENT.
>> THEY ARE NICER TO THE
PROPAGANDAIST.
THAT’S A GOOD POINT.
>> LEFT WING MEDIA IN THE
LAST WEEK HAVE SUPPORTED THE
DICTATORSHIP OF NORTH KOREA.
GIVEN OUT FREE PROPAGANDA.
THIS IS A REGIME THAT HAS